I'd like to welcome everybody to the
second panel of our program it's a panel
on the latest book from Hillsdale
College president Larry Arne the book is
titled the founders key the divine and
natural connection between the
Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it my name is
r.j. post read oh I am a professor of
politics and graduate Dean at the
college and again welcome one of the
things we talk about a great deal in the
politics program at the college is the
the classical notion of practical wisdom
or prudence that was considered central
to the art of statesmanship and I think
it's in the spirit of prudence that I'm
going to refrain from opening myself on
the book written by the man who signs my
paychecks we have instead a
distinguished panel here to handle that
job this morning before introducing them
I will take just a couple of minutes to
acquaint our audience with the books
central argument in the founders key
larry arne articulates the principles of
the American Declaration of Independence
and he contends that these principles
cannot be understood in isolation rather
he explains that in writing the
declaration its authors also outlined
the essential qualities of the
government that would be necessary to
uphold the declarations objectives of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness the Constitution of the United
States aren't argues was the requisite
means of answering the declarations
exhortation to secure man's natural
rights and he contends contrary to some
scholars on both the left and the right
that the founders themselves saw no
disconnect between the argument of the
Declaration and the Constitution at
bottom the connection between the two
documents is this the Declaration estab
is government by consent as the only
form of just government and the
Constitution's limited representative
government organized around the
separation of powers is the only
government fit for the consent of
freemen among other places Arne finds
the foundation for the Constitution in
the declarations list of grievances
against King George the third these
grievances which point to deficiencies
in consent representation limited
government separation of powers these
grievances form than the framework of
the American Constitution it will not be
surprising that Arne's book takes on
critics from the left who for over 100
years have sought to undo the principles
of the Declaration and the limited
government framework of the Constitution
what may not be as well known is that
Aaron's argument also has its share of
critics on the right some there in the
spirit of the anti-federalists still see
the Constitution as a betrayal of the
principles of the Revolution and as a
turning away from genuine republicanism
for an embrace of nationalism or Empire
others on the right are highly
suspicious of the declaration itself
recoiling from what they think are its
philosophic antecedents or seeing in it
the same kind of dangerous abstractions
that make all good conservatives loathe
the French Revolution for these critics
any movement in the Constitution away
from the declaration is in fact a good
thing I suspect our panelists may weigh
in on some of these debates that's why I
will give way to them let me give you
just a short introduction to each here
at the outset and the order in which
they will speak first will be Randy
Barnett Randy Barnett is the Carmack
waterhouse professor of legal
theory at Georgetown University Law
Center
he teaches there constitutional law and
contracts
after graduating from Northwestern
University and Harvard Law School he
tried many felony cases as a prosecutor
in the Cook County State's Attorney's
Office in Chicago he's been a visiting
professor at Northwestern and Harvard
Law School in 2008 he was awarded a
Guggenheim Fellowship in constitutional
studies professor Barnett's publications
include more than 100 articles and
reviews as well as nine books including
restoring the lost Constitution the
presumption of Liberty next will be
Patrick Dineen a Patrick Dineen is the
Frank 'putin siani chair of
constitutional studies at the University
of Notre Dame where he teaches political
theory from 2005 through May of 2012 he
served as associate professor of
government at Georgetown University or
he was the founding director of the
Tocqueville Forum on the roots of
American democracy before that he taught
at Princeton University from 1997 to
2005 as an assistant professor of
government from 1995 to 1997 he was
speechwriter and special advisor to the
director of the United States
Information Agency professor Dineen
received his BA and PhD from Rutgers
University where he studied with the
late Wilson Carrie McWilliams and he's
the author of two books the Odyssey of
political theory and democratic faith
finishing out our panel will be dr.
Larry Arne
Larry Arne is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA
from Arkansas State University
graduating with the highest distinction
he received his MA in government and his
PhD in government from the Claremont
Graduate School he also studied in
England first as a research student in
international history at the London
School of Economics and then in modern
history at Worcester College Oxford
University while in England while in
England he also served as director of
research for Martin Gilbert now Sir
Martin of Merton College Oxford
and the official biographer of Winston
Churchill he returned the United States
and from 1985 to 2000 he served as
president of the Claremont Institute dr.
Arnn is on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Henry Salvatori
Center of Claremont McKenna College and
the Claremont Institute he is author of
Liberty and learning the evolution of
American education published in 2004 his
newest book the founders key is of
course the subject of this panel so
without any further ado we will go to
Professor Burnett well thank you RJ and
thanks to Hillsdale for inviting me to
be on this forum I believe this is the
first time that I've participated in an
official Hillsdale program I'm a huge
fan of Hillsdale College and to
paraphrase Claude Rains in Casablanca I
hope this is the beginning of a
beautiful friendship and also let me
congratulate Larry on his wonderful new
book it's a marvelous book as Blaise
Pascal is reputed to have written I've
made this letter longer than usual
because I lack the time to make it
shorter this book must have taken a long
time to write because it is powerfully
concise its basic message is a vitally
important one the Constitution must be
interpreted with the Declaration of
Independence in mind in my brief remarks
today I'm going to explain why I think
this is the case and in fact it's why
it's how I teach my constitutional law
course at Georgetown now I began my
career as a law professor not as a
constitutional law scholar but as a
contracts professor part of the reason
for that was when I took constitutional
law at Harvard when I was a student I
discovered that every time we got to one
of the good parts in the Constitution
the Supreme Court said it didn't mean
anything and we shouldn't pay any
attention to it so I thought to myself
well if they don't pay any attention to
the Constitution why should i if I'm
gonna go into teaching I'm gonna teach
about something where they do pay
attention to the law and to writings and
contract law was what I chose little did
I know I was going to end up in as a
constitutional law professor after all
of that but there is an important lesson
I learned as a contracts professor and
that is that all writings are incomplete
all writings are
incomplete that's one of the reasons why
they have problems that's why there's
contract law cases about contracts now
this is due to a variety of factors one
is the inadequacy of time to fully
negotiate everything in a contract
secondly an inadequate knowledge of the
future
you just don't know exactly what's going
to happen in the future I don't expect
the things arise that you didn't
anticipate thirdly sort of an under
looked factor if you keep bargaining
about something endlessly to try to
cover all contingencies eventually the
other side's gonna look at you you're
going to say this is not exactly the
sort of person that want to do business
with this guy won't stop bargaining with
me and what about this and what about
that what about this what no I did okay
fine you go I'm gonna find someone else
so at some point you just stop
bargaining and you stop writing and you
can't put everything in there and then
there's a final reason why contracts or
all writings are incomplete and that is
that they're some things that are so
fundamental that they go without saying
they're almost it's almost insulting to
put something into writing you know like
I I you know you agree to be honest with
me you agree not to lie you have things
like that I mean just why would you put
that in there of course that just goes
without saying so it turns out that with
respect to the American Constitution
which is of writing there are two
fundamental assumptions that aren't
clearly expressed in the Constitution
itself although I think that they are
fairly implied and the first is one I'm
not going to spend much time on although
Larry does talk about it in his book and
that is that the Articles of
Confederation are simply not working
well and need to be replaced and Madison
wrote a whole wonderful essay that Larry
talks about called the vices of the
Articles of Confederation which explains
exactly chapter and verse what's the
problem and why the Articles are the
source of that problem it's not really
what I'm going to talk about here the
second fundamental assumption and by the
way that was not an assumption that
everyone in the country shared it was
shared by enough people to eventually
get the Constitution ratified but it was
a deal it was a contested assumption
underlying the Constitution the next
assumption was universally shared by
everyone in the country and that is that
government is meant to secure our
natural rights and if you want a sort of
a shorthand phrase for what this slogan
was or what this position was that
everybody assumed and that is first
comes rights and then comes government
first comes rights and then comes
government was a fundamental assumption
that underlie that everyone agreed with
whether they were for the Constitution
or against it so when we talk about the
relationship of the Declaration of
Independence to the Constitution one of
the most important things about the
Declaration of Independence is that it
makes its definitive evidence of this
second assumption it is a official
written record of the fact that the
founding generation shared this
assumption it tells us that the
foundation of the Revolution and of all
just governments was first comes rights
and then comes government the most
famous line in the Declaration is we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness that is the most famous
sentence in the Declaration and
unfortunately most people don't read
much more than that but the next
sentence in the declaration expresses
the relationship between these rights
and government and the next so the next
sentence is extremely important as well
it says that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed let me just say
that again to secure these rights that
to secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the
government today when democracy is
conceived of as majority rule most of
the stress is placed on the last part of
the sentence
referring to the consent of the governed
and I have to say that that is how RJ's
summary of the book placed it he said
his thesis his description of the thesis
of the book was you have the consent of
the governed and the Constitution is the
way you execute the consent of the
governed and that's the relationship of
the declaration to to the Constitution I
don't really agree I mean that's part of
it but I don't agree with that being the
thrust of it and I don't think it was
the thrust of Larry's book either I
think the thrust of Larry's book is
really unpacking the first part of that
sentence that to secure these rights
governments are instituted it tells us
this sentence does that this part of
this that that these pre-existing
natural rights are the proper end of all
legitimate government not just here but
everywhere and that these natural rights
provide the criteria by which the
legitimacy of government is to be judged
in other words these natural rights do
not go away once government is founded
as some I think moderns tend to think
that they do including modern
conservatives tend to think that they do
if the Declaration is evidence of that
for after all it was the long train of
abuse of those rights it that justified
Americans quote to dissolve the
political bands that have connected them
with another and to assume among the
powers of the earth the separate and
equal station to which the laws of
nature and nature's God entitle them in
other words notwithstanding the fact the
government was created and Americans
were in a civil society with each other
and with the people of Great Britain
notwithstanding all of that because of
the long train abuse of abuses of their
natural rights of the rights that still
existed even though government was
formed they had the they had the right
the rightful power to disassociate
themselves with the political community
that they formerly were associated with
withdraw from that and form their own as
a result of the fact that their natural
rights hadn't violated so they don't go
away once government is founded and they
don't go away once this government is
founded so the relationship of these two
documents then I think is rather clear
and elegant the the written Declaration
of Independence brilliantly and movingly
describes the end of all legitimate
government that is to secure these
natural rights the while the written
Constitution describes the means to that
end
the Articles of Confederation was a
means to that end but it wasn't at least
according to those who adopted the
Constitution and adequate one and we
could do better and they did do better I
think in many respects by adopting the
Constitution as the means to the end of
securing those rights that is the
fundamental relationship of the
Declaration of Independence to the
Constitution now when I teach all this
on the first day of my constitutional
law class the Georgetown which I did
this semester I have to spend time
explaining to my students what the heck
natural rights are since this is not the
part of any of their education unless
they went to Hillsdale College the first
now the first thing I have to do I have
to say to convince them of the
plausibility of the idea of natural
rights is to point out that all of them
are many of them
they're right thinking people right
thinking in the sense of progressive
they all believe in what they call human
rights human rights or something and
what our human rights what do they think
human rights I they think they are the
things that governments can violate if
they torture if they do this if they do
that but that they are independent of
government and are a criteria by which
you assess government and since they
believe in human rights they themselves
believe that first comes rights and then
comes government even if we may disagree
about what that what they are but it's
less mysterious if they realize they
themselves invoke the idea and we hit
they haven't moved completely beyond it
the second thing that I have to say is
that natural rights are not really any
more mysterious than the principles that
are discovered in any in such
disciplines as agriculture engineering
and medicine now unlike the descriptive
disciplines of say physics or biology
which merely try to describe or explain
the world as we know it these other
disciplines I just listed agriculture
engineering and medicine are what we
might call normative disciplines but by
that I mean they are designed to
instruct human beings in how to act they
are there to tell you what to do under
certain circumstances how to act under
certain circumstances so for example if
you want to grow crops for human
consumption build buildings for human
occupancy and make sick human beings
well then you had best follow the basic
principles or precepts of these
disciplines of these normative
disciplines and these principles when
people say here about natural rights
they say well where are these natural
rights tell me where they are
yeah they in the dirt are they in the
sky I don't see them where are they well
we don't say that about principles of
medicine engineering and agriculture do
we we don't say well you know we're
gonna find those principles of
agriculture in the dirt go look in the
dirt you'll see how to grow crops you
know we're gonna find the principles of
medicine just undo the body you know cut
open the body you'll see the principle
no no no no of course these are human
constructions human concepts meant to
solve problems on the basis of what on
the basis of the nature of soil and
nutrients and and and the things that
grow in them on the basis the nature of
the body when it comes to engineering
the nature of the of the properties of
the various things that go into making
up these buildings these are all based
on the nature of the
world we find themselves if you want to
accomplish certain ends you had best
respect these means in order to
accomplish those ends natural rights can
simply be recharacterized and they were
in fact at the time recharacterized as
simply principles of society these are
the fundamental principles of society if
you want a society in which people can
pursue happiness while enjoying peace
and prosperity then you had best respect
these basic fundamental natural rights
that's all it is it's no more mysterious
than these other principles so here's a
rough and ready test empirical test of
how different societies do in protecting
basic natural rights because as you know
it's if these if the claim is right if
natural rights in fact are the
principles of society by which you can
achieve happiness peace and prosperity
then there would be an empirical a test
or an empirical result or outcome of
violating those rights here's a
rough-and-ready empirical test see which
way the refugees are running see which
countries they're leaving trying to get
out of in which countries they're trying
to get into
it's a comparative test it doesn't mean
the place they're trying to get into is
a perfect respecter of natural rights
only that they're doing a better job of
it
and again there's other confounding
variables for example welfare policies
can attract people to a country even if
that's not a subject of natural rights
but nevertheless it is still a very good
indicator when people are trying to us
when you put up a wall you're trying to
keep the people out or you're trying to
keep the people in that's sort of an
empirical test no case so finally not by
me and me not finally almost finally
what are these natural rights what
options you see that's the $64,000
question I'm not going to be able to
answer that in a few minutes but let me
give you a basic conclusion and some
reasons for before understanding that
put simply they are Liberty rights
natural rights are Liberty rights
they're not the only rights we have and
they are not the only rights we need we
need other rights rights that are the
creation of government you form
government to create additional rights
like for example the right of protection
I'll say that more about that in a
second but natural rights are the rights
you start with natural the rights for
the Bright's you have before you have a
government they are Liberty rights but
not Liberty and the Hobbesian sense of
doing anything you will or desire that's
not the kind of Liberty rights they are
that's not the kind of Liberty rights
for example that libertarians believe in
Hobbes II and Liberty rights know the
founders believe in liberty rights in
the Lockean sense and that is the
Liberty is the freedom to do what you
will with what's yours it's the freedom
to do what you will with what's yours
think of it this way every individual is
a sovereign ruler of all within his or
her jurisdiction private property
defines the boundaries of each of our
jurisdictions with Witten within which
we are supposed to be the sovereign we
are supposed to be the king properly
defined property rights eliminate
conflicts among the jurisdictions of the
sovereign citizens as Larry writes in
his book
nothing properly called a right takes
anything from anyone else that's
something you can only really say about
a liberty right the declaration tells us
that the first and highest duty of
government is to protect these rights in
fact it ends up getting put into the
Fourteenth Amendment as the Equal
Protection Clause that is the duty of
the states to protect the rights of the
citizens as Locke taught it is better to
secure these it is to better secure
these rights that we move from a state
of nature where each of us must enforce
or execute them on our own behalf to
delegate the executive power of
enforcement to the government that's the
rationale for setting up government in
the first place
government must make us better off by
better protecting our rights than we can
protect them ourselves but this means
the governments that systematically fail
to protect or even violate these rights
are not fulfilling their reason for
existence and therefore can be
illegitimate what the exact conditions
are of the legitimacy I'm going to
bracket that for a moment because an
individual rights violation is not
enough to render a whole government
illegitimate in fact the Declaration
teaches us that it's a long train of
abuses that justifies replacing one
government with another the founders
knew all this and designed a
constitution to secure these rights if
we follow it and sadly we have not but
the Constitution I've actually say we
have not followed all of it as I already
mentioned that's what I learned when I
was in constitutional law but the
Constitution was so well designed that
even though whole portions of it are
misconstrued or completely ignored and
the ignored parts are what I what my
book is about there is
it's called restoring the lost
Constitution what I mean by the lost
Constitution is not a good old days when
constitutional law was great
it's the parts of the Constitution that
are gone and that are not there anymore
that's the lost Constitution the
Constitution is so welded was so well
designed that even with large parts of
it missing the parts that remain have
still kept us relatively free it's like
flying in a well designed for engine jet
after three of the engines have failed
because the plane is well designed it
can still say a lot stay aloft with one
engine but it's a far more vulnerable
and precarious state to try to do that
than to fly on all four engines what we
need to do constitutionally in this
country is get the other three engines
fired up but to do this we first need to
appreciate that the end that the end of
government and the purpose that
underlies the Constitution a purpose so
fundamental that it largely went without
saying in the Constitution itself the
Declaration of Independence stands as a
written official and moving testimony to
this underlying assumption Larry Ahrens
book is a beautifully written and
mercifully concise explanation of this
relationship which makes it a violet
vital tool to restoring our lost
Constitution and for this I thank him
well I too want to thank begin by
thanking Hillsdale College I realized I
also have never appeared in an official
capacity although I know many many of
the faculty at Hillsdale proffer have
for many years including its Provost
David Whalen I suppose though unlike
professor Barnett my role here is to
lodge some objections and so I won't
expect an invitation back as much as
much as I would like one but before I
raised some concerns about the argument
of dr. arns book and I think they were
well telegraphed by RJ pastry dough so
I'm brought in to criticize from the
right to show that there's an even more
dangerous form right-winger ism than
than that which is portrayed out there
today in the popular media but I too
would like to express my gratitude to
dr. Arnn for this for this book for its
seriousness for its sustained attention
and it's it's probing exploration of the
vital relationship of the principles
underlying the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution of
their relationship and I think further
the relationship that they both bear to
the world that in some respects they
created and that's something about what
I want to talk about in this way dr.
Arnn
is not only speaking about the
Constitution that document that we can
read and interpret but I think he's
evoking a more ancient understanding of
Constitution a constitution as Aristotle
describes it that builds a way of life
sometimes translated as regime I don't
mean this in the Rush Limbaugh sense but
but rather that that fosters a kind of
way of living in fact on page four dr.
Arnn writes that the way that we talk
the way that we stand the way that we
dance or sing all are influenced by the
laws of the land and the principles
behind them and our laws and principles
spring from these laws and these
documents and I think anyone who's
traveled abroad and has encountered
another American no matter in some ways
where they're from
you immediately sense these are one of
my people you you there is something
really palpable and
about being a part of the American
regime that goes beyond simply how we
have that Constitution it builds a way
of life but this very claim and I think
it's a central claim and I think it's a
correct claim that the Constitution the
Declaration and its underlying
principles established a regime a way of
life actually stands as a challenge to
the overarching thesis of dr. arns book
and not only dr. arns book but a
narrative that a number of of my friends
and many many estimable authors have
have developed over the last number of
years including the lunch speaker today
dr. Kessler dr. s Trudeau and I think
popped their eyes in some of the columns
of George Will and even in the
television programming of Glenn Beck
back when you had a television show this
thisis a night and I don't mean to be
reductionist but I don't have a lot of
time suggest that for much of human
history there was a continuity in the
main claims about what it is to be a
human under law that begin to be
articulated in antiquity by some of all
the authors like Plato and Aristotle and
then Cicero continued to be articulated
through the Christian era to the Middle
Ages and then into early modern times
the founding the American Founding and
one of the reasons it's exceptional that
word we hear a lot about today is that
the founding represents the practical
culmination and realization of this long
history of the development of a set of
ideas wet which had been until that time
merely theory but which because of a
concatenation of happy events pilgrims
coming over the the revolution a kind of
practice of representative government
only America for the first time in world
history was able to realize in fact
however there's a downside and a sad
side to this narrative that only a
hundred years later after the thousand
years building or more than a thousand
years building of this tradition and the
culmination in the founding of America
100 years later beginning at the end of
the nineteenth and then the beginning of
the 20th centuries that entire tradition
is if not overturned severely challenged
and put under duress
by the introduction
aborts broadly called historicism or
what we today call progressivism which
in fact the Democratic Party now is
called progressivism
moreover progressivism is a foreign
import it's like a BMW it comes from
Germany it comes especially from elite
thinkers in America who go to study with
a number of German thinkers who believe
that history is in some ways a perk
takes a progressive course and so that
we must look with a kind of an
understanding of the past that we are
always superior to those who have
preceded us where from whence comes the
elitism of progressives well that which
has preceded us the past is always
inferior to that which has followed it
so history not only has a direction but
a direction always toward greater
greater progress so within a hundred
years the work of the founders and the
culmination of centuries of
philosophical work comes undone and
continues to be undone until this day
now in a nutshell this thesis while I
again I've stated it crudely while that
I think is a very useful one and I think
it is politically useful I find it in
fact as a perhaps an intellectual to be
highly implausible I finally be hauling
a highly implausible among other things
because it seems to me such a solid
foundation something that builds a way
of life would have would have a lasting
power for more than merely a century and
what I'd like to do today is to offer an
alternative thesis and one that is
disconcerting to those of us who are
friends the Constitution at least to
some extent but worry worry about
whether or not in some ways it is in
some ways complicit and the belief was
well articulated by dr. Barnett that the
belief it engenders in some ways
contributes to our current condition is
not simply a contradiction of our
current condition in my narrative then
the founding represents not the
continuity and culmination of a long
tradition but a rupture that arose
especially at the beginnings I mean it
had a long period of time developing but
the currents especially arising from the
Protestant Reformation a decisive break
with antiquity and that America is the
first regime founded on
specifically a set of modern principles
ones derived in the first instance from
Machiavelli from Hobbes and Locke I'm a
political theorist this is modern for me
the Renaissance is really modern and I
further want to suggest that rather than
progressivism being a rupture that in
many ways progressivism grew out of the
soil of this rupture that is introduced
by the American Founding that there's
more continuity than tends to be noticed
between progressives and
constitutionalists then we tend to
notice in our current contemporary
political debates so let me just offer
in very brief my - the two reasons why I
hold this view first that the founding
represents a break with antiquity and
I'm actually gonna use many of the same
phrases and sentences as proof of my
argument that dr. Arnn uses in in in
support of his argument as Hamilton
Alexander Hamilton notes at the very in
the very first of the Federalist Papers
he writes it has frequently been
remarked that it seems to have been
reserved to the people of this country
to decide by their conduct and example
whether societies of men are really
capable or not of establishing good
government from reflection and choice or
whether they are forever forced to
depend for their political constitutions
on accident and force in a subsequent
paper he notes advances in the science
of politics ones that render all
previous regimes illegitimate in
comparison to the to the principles that
have been established and embraced in
America and those principles that have
been derived from the Constitution and
from the Declaration those principles
break with the ancient tradition I want
to suggest in the following ways not
only as has been suggested by professor
Barnett but in the following ways first
there's an argument that political
society must and cannot but be based
upon the fundamental wellspring of
self-interest
this is the only reliable wellspring
that can be in some ways predictably
relied upon and expected in the course
of human affairs but this represents a
major break with the ancient and the
Christian tradition which argued for the
edge of the human soul
argued in fact for the possibility of
the education of the human being and the
citizenry inverts you and that this took
place in particular on smaller scales
ideally and why in the ancient
republican tradition there was a stress
on locality on smallness as opposed to
greatness
Madison in addressing some of these
fundamental questions about what is the
nature of the human being and are we
educate asked a famous question again
quoted by dr. Arnn and maybe many of you
may perhaps know this quote what is
government itself but the greatest of
all reflections on human nature if men
were angels no government would be
necessary that is that is he's
suggesting Madison is suggesting in
Federalist 51 if humans were naturally
good there would be no need for
government no need for law right we
would just be naturally good we wouldn't
have to have a government but human
beings are not naturally good we are
naturally prone to self-interest to
self-aggrandizement to pry to sin we
inescapably do ill to others we are
inescapably driven by our self-interest
and why a madison argues that when we
established the government ambition must
be made to counteract ambition we won't
seek the reduction of of harmful
ambition we will seek to counteract its
presence we will harness self-interest
we won't to seek to overcome it
elsewhere in Federalist 10 he famously
articulates that moral and religious
motives cannot be relied upon right we
can't rely on them in the same way that
we can rely on self-interest as a basic
motivation in politics but I want I want
you to notice I'll say it the outright
blasphemy of Madison suggestion I used
to teach a Princeton so I think he
learned this at Princeton what does
government it suffer the greatest of all
reflections on human nature if men were
angels no government would be necessary
well as far as I can understand by my
reading of scripture and other documents
the angels are under government there
are never of tyrannical government in
fact they're under there under a monarch
and we could point out
among other things that they're not
always good Lucifer was kind of a
problematic angel who seemed not to have
obeyed the government the law but I
think what's more important and what
Madison doesn't notice because of his
fundamental assumptions about human
nature government and human motivation
is that government only exists to
prevent ill to prevent evil but in the
angelic and divine understanding
government God's government exists in
some ways because of the natural order
of things among other things not natural
rights but natural law it's built into
the fabric of the world that certain
things are right and just and certain
things are not and whether one is
naturally good or not government exists
in some ways as a natural expression of
that order this is why John Milton
portrays Satan portrays the fallen angel
Lucifer as desiring Liberty which he
believes is the capacity to escape from
the law his ideal understanding of
Liberty is the capacity to escape from
the law but we discovered that the truly
free angel is Michael because Michael
submits himself to the law and in the in
this submission discovers his Liberty
his Liberty is in a beat to be in
accordance with the divine law I think
this this basic understanding and a
submission by Madison suggests that for
Madison the soul is in educable we are
always and fundamentally driven by
self-interest and all that government in
some ways can do is prevent us from
doing harm to each other but it can in
some ways leaven the ground in the world
for the cultivation of virtue and when I
look around our world today and trying
to raise my children in a world where
there's very little evidence of virtue
in our culture I find myself longing for
a time and longing even for the capacity
of our public world to help a foster
that kind of a ground the best the best
way in which this this teaching of
Madison's is to be achieved is to
enlarge the scale of the government not
the government's are too large the scale
of the nation and to increase the size
the mad
in the might of the nation but it's
admitted throughout the Federalist
Papers that this will come at the
expense of identification with the local
as Hamilton writes in Federalist 17 it
is a known fact in human nature that
human affections are commonly weak and
proportion to the distance of the
diffusive nosov the object how far away
something is the people of each state
are apt to feel a stronger bias toward
their local governments than toward the
government of the Union unless he writes
the force of that principle should be
destroyed by a much larger
administration of the latter so he
admits an exception to this normal
default understanding of human beings
that we prefer the local over the over
the National except at the center the
central government is better
administered and then ten papers later
in number 27 he says that because the
government will draw as he states a
select body of men it will induce a
probability that the general government
the central government will be better
administered than the particular
governments so acknowledges that the
proviso the exception is actually will
likely come to pass and again when I
read this morning's newspapers that
seven and the counties of the country's
ten most wealthiest counties are in the
DC area it does strike me how this
Center has just increasingly drawn all
of the talent and the wealth of the
country to this place and this is
perhaps not as much in contradiction to
to Hamilton's vision as we might suppose
I've spoke probably at too much I mean
to speak very briefly to why I think
that this basic set of assumptions lead
to ground that becomes fertile for the
movement of progressivism first and
drawing out of this this that that last
point that I made there is shared by
many of the many of the founders as well
as progressives a kind of hostility to
local culture what one might call the
genius of place an orientation toward
liberation from the particular from the
cultural from the traditional as dr.
Arnn suggests in reading the Declaration
I quote it hardly
like a document from any particular
world at all it's written for every
human but not for people in particular
cultures and places there was no less a
valorisation of progress among the
founding generation as as one finds
among the progressives and I could I
could provide a few many quotes and
pieces of evidence but I think from the
very beginning of the American project a
strong emphasis upon progress as the as
the basic orientation and wellspring
which from the very beginning as I
indicated in that quote of Hamilton
already puts under suspicion that which
has proceeded right the same indictment
that is made against today's
progressives they don't respect that
which happened in the past well what
does Hamel do Hamilton doing in
Federalist one but dismissing everything
that has happened in the past and saying
we for the first time have done these
things and lastly an interesting and
perhaps inescapable relationship between
the anthropological individualism the
Lockean assumptions of natural rights
that lies at the heart of the
Declaration and the Constitution that
relates it ultimately to a kind of
anthropological collectivism and I think
that the author here and one someone
that hasn't been mentioned yet and is
only I think mentioned once in dr. arns
book but since I used to lead a
programmer I founded a program at
Georgetown by this name the author I
think that teaches us best about this is
Alexy to talk about what Tocqueville saw
and I think foresaw was a time when in
the effort to escape from place from
locality from tradition from culture in
order to be to be common to fulfill the
vision of Liberty that was in some ways
held out in the imaginings of the early
philosophy that in some ways culminates
in our tradition that that very
liberation would lead up leave but leave
us increasingly alone bereft of help and
assistance and we would turn
increasingly to the one body the one
place that could afford us assistance
and which he describes as the vast and
tutelary state the vast and tutelary
state he says arises not from a
collectivist impulse
but in the first instance out of a kind
of rampant individuals and that leaves
us bereft of help believes us bereft of
the assistance of entities that are
sub-national and so for those of us who
care deeply about the fate of this
country for those of us who share I
think dr. arns deep commitments to
limited government deep commitments to a
government that is not simply attempting
to govern all of our behavior and all of
our actions I would hope that Hillsdale
College the Kirby Center will stress as
much not only the need to restore the
Constitution which seems to me it's
necessary but insufficient condition but
like Tocqueville stress those
sub-national entities the health of our
families the the the solidity and
stability of our communities the central
role of our churches our religious
institutions that area of civil society
that ought to flourish in some ways in
spite of in many ways what might be
happening in Washington DC
I've left Washington in part because I
wanted to leave Washington not only
physically but to leave it behind and to
care more for its closer than what's far
away so I thank you
so it's a obviously an absurd thing for
a fellow like me to write a book the sad
truth is my book is short because I
didn't have time to write a long one
Randy got it exactly backwards and now I
have placed myself at the mercy of
highly intelligent and even brilliant
and learned people and they've been kind
to me but of course they have enormous
advantages over me because I do spend so
very much of my time managing things
like organizing to sign our J post
readers paycheck when they called me
about this job 12 years ago I actually
laughed at them it's the third time I've
been called about a college president
job and all three times I laughed at
them and they said I said I don't want
that job that's a terrible job and they
said why and I said most of my friends
are faculty members I know what they
think about college presidents and sure
enough from these two guys my
introduction began with one of them
mentioning that I have some authority
over him and the other one began by the
other one ended by mentioning a policy
he recommends me to implement here at
Hillsdale College and the prayer in the
Kirby Center I point all that out and
while I do that I think these three
because of their quality and the
goodness they've shown I think Randy
because Lord has he not done wonderful
service to our country lately but also
in addition he has been in all though he
hardly knows it I mentioned it to him
one time a teacher of mine now for more
than a decade because I learned a long
time ago like the first thing he taught
me is something he wrote probably four
hundred years ago about what the
Necessary and Proper Clause means and I
was having a fight with somebody about
that and I went looking and I found
something he wrote and I didn't know who
he was it's time and I said boy this
guy's good and so now commonly I go look
for him what I'm trying to settle
something and to have him here today is
a great honor and pleasure Patrick
professor demean is a
defender of things that I very much love
an enable and distinguished defender of
them he he has taught in fine places a
very fine place right now unlike him I
have the honor never to have lived in
this city and but he recovered and he's
gone now but he's a faithful and kind
and studious man and highly intelligent
and he's been good to me we have our
differences and I'll comment on them
shortly and about RJ it would be
imprudent for me to comment on the
quality of a colleague except to say
that I made him the Dean of something
has been dear to my heart for more than
twenty years now and I do not regret it
at all I'll say back to it I'll say a
little bit about what my book says right
at the end just briefly because they've
all talked about it and the book is
you've learned it short you can read it
if you want to but about what they've
said I'll say - two main things - Randy
and then a couple - professor Janine
first writes then government is correct
but it's also correct to say rights and
government human beings are political
animals they always live under law the
nature of them it comes from the fact
that they can talk and this is
recognized in the Declaration of
Independence they say that we may throw
off the government and then we institute
new government so there's it's a it's a
the conjunction and and then I make
something out of Joseph Ellis who was
invited to be here today and had to
cancel and he's I don't know him but I
admire him a lot and I like his work but
Lord doesn't he say in one of his books
on the founding that the Detroit
independent streets government is an
alien force whereas the Constitution
does not whereas the
charges against the king dwell upon the
fact that he has thwarted government
beginning with the first of the charges
against the king he has refused his
assent to laws the most wholesome and
necessary for the public good the public
good cannot be served except under a
regime of law and that it is recognized
in the American Founding as it is in the
pages of Aristotle and I don't think
that there's any exception to it John
Locke has not mentioned in the
Declaration of Independence that of
course independence must be read as a
document and remember the situation in
which the Declaration of impendence is
written it is written in a atmosphere of
the threat of execution there is a
warrant out for the arrest of everyone
who signed that document and it's the
warrant is not given to a lawful civil
officer it is given to a general and his
army is he's told to use his army and
find these men even if it it causes a
general congregation and so what they
say in the document they thought
carefully about it
Jefferson was chosen because everybody
knew he could write and knew he could
eat he had the ideas and he was young so
don't forget that every human society of
which we have any written record lives
under laws and the people who founded
the United States of America knew that
thing these laws must operate now if you
read Randy's work which I just told you
I do with great profit all the time he
has a wonderful way of describing of
working out how it is as my second point
about consent how it is consent actually
works practically although he says and
in a literal fact he's right we don't
really consent to our government well
then why should we have it and his
answer in this works is if I get it
wrong you can fix it is that his answer
is yeah okay but broadly we do
and it protects our rights and our
rights are in our nature and that word
nature you just won't be able to end up
using that word nature for very long
unless you come to mean two things by it
and one is the thing itself what makes
it what it is if we brought a pig in
this room all the differences among all
the people in this room would diminish
and importance that everybody would turn
and say what's that pig doing in here
there's a great story about that you
know they put a pig on somebody took a
pig on USAir Philadelphia to San
Francisco as the therapeutic pet
companion I talk about that in my book
the name of the pig was Charlotte and
the pig misbehaved terribly there wasn't
just the bathroom habits of the pig
there was the snout up the women's
dresses and you know you can eat the pig
and you cannot eat the human right and
that distinction in nature that's what
that word means but also that word
nature means the process of beginning
and growth by which people come to be
any living thing right so our nature
includes our families the way of our
birth all of that now that is a good
place for me to turn to Professor
Jeanine because he he first of all he's
right about a lot of that just not the
main things in my opinion
and he raises understand and see he does
it by the way with such a good you know
thank God he's doing it he's raising in
a very intelligent way the question
whether the founding of the United
States of America was a good thing and
by the founding I mean legal acts that
brought it into being the big things
that happened and you know some those
things happen and those things have
changed the world in a big way and he's
raising the question whether that's good
or not and his key point is that it's a
break was antiquity and you have to
reply to that and the break was
antiquity has to do with the fact that
now there's a universal principle
operating and that works is some kind of
solvent I think you right somewhere that
undoes the family and our religious
connections well first of all I don't
think the break was antiquity is so
great as he does because you can't get
away from the idea that there are
natural rights in for example Aristotle
whom about whom I have to know something
if you read his discussion of slavery
and book one of the politics on the one
hand he does say that slavery is not
gonna go away although he says if the
shuttle could weave or the plectrum
strike of itself in other words if you
had technology to do the work then you
wouldn't enslave people on the other
hand slavery is only right in the case
of the incapacitated person that means
if somebody is unable to guide
themselves as every human being and the
overwhelming majority of human beings
can only in that case is it right and so
in the ancient world there's a
contradiction right there's it's not
perfect then a big chain so so but but
you can't get away from the fact that
the idea that there's a justice that
stands outside the will of any of us
that that has something to do with the
right the right way to teach to treat a
human being of the nature of the human
being now there is a difference between
the United States
and its founding in the ancient world
but that difference has something to do
with a much greater revolutionary than
anything that happened in the American
Revolution and that is Jesus Christ
happens between the ancient world and
the modern world and Jesus Christ is a
incredible revolutionary and by the way
the changes that he made are not
dissimilar from the changes to which
professor to name objects against the
United States because what does he do
except make our salvation the work of
each individual one of us and overturned
the law and the sense of community in
the mosaic world in the Old Testament
and make the religion Universal and
beyond the boundaries of countries and
by the way I think that's a great thing
I mean it's a radical understatement to
say that I think that's a great thing I
think that's part of the providential
plan for all of the universe and I think
by the way the Jewish experience is a
step on the way to that I said that with
respect to Jewish people vote we have
many at our college and and so I think
that's a great thing but you have to
understand that changes something about
politics something big because now all
of a sudden religion and the law are not
the same thing anymore if the maker says
my kingdom is not of this world then
that means that all of a sudden we're
going to make our own laws and those
laws by the way are going to have to be
limited if there's going to be the
freedom to practice one's faith
regardless what country he lives in so
that's a change that's a huge change
from the ancient world and how are we
going to cope with that is it true that
the founders of the United States meant
to destroy the family for example in
local communities as a matter of fact
what they did you can read the works of
Tom West to find that out is they
strengthen the laws that govern too
family divorce got harder after the
American Revolution than it was before
and then in addition you can say that
it's true that at the federal level they
don't say much about the family that's a
fact they don't but by the way the
things that Jesus himself says about the
family are ambiguous now I think I know
what they mean I think by the way that
Jesus did the same thing that the
founders did I think that he added
protections over those that existed in
the Mosaic law but that's not uniformly
what he says I shall turn father against
son mother against daughter is at the
quote it's not the only quote or the
meaning of the quotes except to say that
one is facing an eternal world that's
beyond anything in this world
now lest I be accused of a blasphemy
that I compare the founding to the work
of Jesus I actually regard it as
obedient to that work that's what I mean
I submit to this audience as I do in my
book that the duck price of Independence
has these features that it is first of
all a constitutional document it
requires a form of rule and that form of
rule is derived from the nature of the
human being which by the way does not
deny that the human being is edgy cool
edgy Keable in fact it constructs a
system the purpose of which is to make
for example Madison says in the 51st
Federalist which which which professor
to name quoted extensively he says that
thing about government and difference
between men and angels right well
obviously that quote doesn't assert that
angels are uncovered it means that
they're not subject to human government
because the government God's governance
of the universe is written into the
fabric of the Declaration of
Independence with the four mentions of
God three of them as branches of
government the lesson being obvious he's
the maker of the laws of nature and
nature's God he's divine
and he's the supreme judge of the world
and the obvious meaning of those three
things is if God were ruling us directly
instead of leaving us free from that
governance then you could combine all
the powers of government in one set of
hands and that by the way that quote
about men and angels is a direct
reference back to that structure and we
have to remember that James Madison and
Thomas Jefferson were the closest of
friends including at this time so I
believe I believe that it's a
constitutional document and that it
looks to the improvement of man else
Madison cannot make the point throughout
the Federalist that one of the things
that's going to happen is speech is
going to become more candid and honest
after the constitution because we're
going to have to talk across a wider
scope about the things that are national
although the things that are local will
remain local thank God for it I submit
that the Declaration the Constitution of
the United States are both reverential
documents they both look up to God in
their structure and in the
justifications that are that were given
to the given for them especially the
declarations where it is by the way
explicit in the text and throughout the
text and because they are reverential I
submit that they are acts of obedience
not revolution they are obedience to the
laws of nature and of nature's God and
and I think that because they have these
qualities they are exactly the thing
that is required for the world after the
birth of Jesus Christ which has changed
so much from antiquity and I believe by
the way that most of the modern attempts
to recover the ancient practices of
community are in fact romantic in their
nature they are an attempt to recreate a
thing on a different basis and generally
although certainly not in the case of
professor Jeanine upon a scientific
basis and that is dangerous and that is
characteristic of progressivism from
which the founders of America are
sharply and over
they distinguished and by the way so
clearly so that all you have to do is
come with me this afternoon and ride
your bicycle about town and look at the
buildings and you will see the
difference between the works that they
have wrought thank you
okay well thank you to our panel for the
presentations I think I'll allow some
time for some some intra panel questions
if there if there are any the first
Burnett thanks very much I have a couple
of responses or additional points I want
to make first with respect to what Larry
said about the consent of the governed
it's true than in my book I point out
that we're never really asked for our
consent of the government's consent in
that sense as a fiction the kind of
consent you do have to have to enter
into a contract we never have to
manifest to our government and that's a
problem that's a problem and I do think
one way of reconciling the consent of
the governed which is in the declaration
with the with the first part of that
sentence which has to do is to secure
these rights is to understand all
acknowledge that problem realize that
the only consent that could possibly be
claimed for government is what you might
call hypothetical consent or what
actually what they called at the time
theoretical or presumed consent and if
you're only going to operate on the
basis of presumed consent then as Locke
tells us no one can be presumed to have
left the state of nature to enter in a
civil society except to make themselves
better off it's the only reason why they
could ever have done that and you would
not be better off if you gave up all
your rights the holy reason to leave the
state of nature is to make yourself
better off with respect to securing your
rights and that's the reason why the
fact that we are not asked for our
consent and our consent can only be
presumed is the reason why the
government even under this constitution
should not be is not authorized to
violate our fundamental rights unless
there's an expressed statement in there
that says they can do something like
that in which case then we can't object
on positive law grounds but you'll find
remarkably few such statements like that
in the Constitution that even are
arguably rights violating until perhaps
we got to the income tax amendment so
that was that that's the first thing I
would say about consent now I want to
take say a word about Patrick's point
about the fact that the founding
represents a break from the past a break
from antiquity I think in some respects
it does and in a way that I would be in
favor of rather than one that I'd be
opposed to when I was an undergraduate I
became very much influenced by my
professor Henry Veatch who was a very
famous Aristotelian Thomas philosopher
and Christian and he became in a sense
my intellectual mentor and while I was
an undergraduate I came across the
concept of natural rights reading on my
own which is always a dangerous thing
for an undergraduate to do and I came
back to my professor and I said Henry I
didn't say Henry I didn't you took me
years before I could call him Henry I
said Professor beech what about this
natural right stuff I was very excited
this seems like real listings like
everything you've been telling us and he
said no that natural rights that's a
modern thing that's it that's it that's
something you got to be really that's
not so good I could tell he was very
diplomatic he was a very grand fatherly
like character he did not reproach me
but I felt like oh wait a second I just
stepped in something I didn't realize
that stepped in that's when I learned
that the natural law tradition is not
always hospitable to the natural rights
that came about during the Enlightenment
period this was a very good lesson to me
interestingly enough by the time before
he passed away
Henry under the influence of some
philosophers who have a libertarian or
libertarian inclined he actually was
induced to change his mind he wrote his
last book was called human rights factor
fancy in which he argued there was such
a thing as natural rights our natural
law grounds which I thought was an
interesting thing for him to do wasn't
under my influence I wish I could claim
credit so in a way yes natural rights
was a modern invention modern
development
it's an Enlightenment development it's
one the we are founding is based on but
I also think it actually is not
completely discontinuous with the past
in a way that Larry already alluded to
with respect to Aristotle I want to
allude to it with respect to Thomas
Aquinas himself by just reading you a
passage from question 96 of the Summa
Theologica which has to do with the
power of human law and should human law
repress all vices and in here I think
you're not going to see a natural rights
position but you'll see the seeds of a
natural rights position here and here's
what Thomas says an answer to the
question should human law repress all
vices now human law is framed for a
number of human beings the majority of
whom are not perfect in virtue we're for
human laws do not forbid all vices from
whom from which it is possible for the
majority to abstain and and chiefly
those that are to the hurt of others
they should only forbid those to the
herd of others without the prohibition
of which human society could not be
maintained
thus humans human law prohibits murder
theft and suchlike
in fact the very crimes I became a Cook
County State's Attorney to prosecute
murder theft and suchlike so a lot of
such like in Chicago but there was
plenty of murder and death too so so
what he's suggesting here is that human
law should basically focus on those
things that are of harm to others now
this is just a nation thought but you
can see the seeds are here it is not the
province of human law to make everybody
virtuous although it's he says obviously
to encourage virtue and this is what
this is you know in a sense with the
natural rights tradition builds upon and
that is that the natural rights
tradition is answering a different
question in the natural law tradition
that the natural law ethics tradition is
answering the natural f penises last
point I'll make RJ the natural law
ethics position is answering the
question how should we live our life and
I'm still a natural law ethics person
for that reason I think that's the best
way of going about thinking about how we
should live our life that's what Henry
was teaching me all those years ago
that's what natural law is about natural
rights is actually using the same
methodology to answer a different
question and the different question is
how should society be structured so that
people can live their lives
that's a substantially different
question then how should we live our
life and did write a run-run one into
the other I think is to make a category
mistake and it's actually to lead to
really bad stuff that can the idea if
you if human government is there to tell
us how to live our lives that could
actually lead to very bad state of
affairs so it's very important to
distinguish between the issue of how we
live our life according to our natures
and the issue of how society should be
structured so as to allow us and permit
us and facilitate us to live our life
according to our natures and the second
the answer to the second question is the
natural rights answer and that's the
answer that the founders had and that's
the answer on which both the Declaration
in the Constitution depend I want to
thank dr. Arnn especially for his
thoughtful response I one of the great I
think
descriptions of conservatives is they
they all share one fundamental belief
that at some point in the past something
went very wrong but we disagree bitterly
about what that date was
I want to just I guess for the record
agree I hope that it wasn't understood
that I was arguing that the founders
either explicitly or implicitly or
surreptitiously had a grand plan to
undermine the family community church it
said Aaron would it be delighted by what
they saw today I don't think that for a
moment what I do hope I was able to at
least suggest is that there were some
fundamental let's say philosophical
assumptions that have acted and I think
the word solvent was used and that's the
word I would use has acted like a
solvent over a long period of time on a
certain set of fundamental commitments
that I think for in drawing on this
older tradition that were understood to
be in some ways natural to us and
constitutive of who we are that we are
not born that we are not created as
autonomous individuals who simply and
always consent to our relationships but
we are rather born into a fabric into a
narrative into a tradition that we are
constituted by our past as much as we
constitute aspects of our future and
it's that narrative of self creation
that begins with lock or Hobbes idea of
the state of nature that we are always
and everywhere in some ways if not
literally consenting that that idea is
some ways the normative idea that
motivates how we think about a
relationship not only to government but
as Locke suggests in some of the
chapters in the second treatise on
government to things like our families
where he writes that who we in the sense
who we are and what our relationship to
our parents will be and what a
relationship ultimately to our children
will be will be the same consequence of
consent as that that's acted in the
state of nature and when all human
relationships are subject to this logic
relentless logic of consent and choice
it leads like a solvent to the weakening
and eventually even the evaporation of
the fundamental and stable basis of
those ties so I want to suggest not that
the founders are culpable for what I
would regard as many of the pathologies
of our modern world but rather embrace
an initiative philosophy that perhaps
unbeknownst and unpredictable by them
have led us to a pass that I think many
of us would share
a sense of lamentation about where we
are and I would only caution us that
rather than simply regarding a
restoration of our constitutional order
as sufficient that we think hard about
what would be necessary to restore the
basis the kind of stability of those
relationships that seems to me are
fundamentally the basis of what a good
society is thank you very much I will in
a moment here turn it over for questions
I will I suppose take the privilege of
the chair
- I think offer one up one observation
might be useful to think about as we
consider the distinction between the
founders and the progressives and the
the the narrative that Professor Dineen
talked about and the possibility that he
suggests that there was some complicity
you know in the founding itself in terms
of the development of progressivism
later and and that is the observation as
someone who reads a lot of the
progressives when you read a lot of the
progressive intellectuals John Dewey
Woodrow Wilson Theodore Roosevelt
Herbert Crowley people like this there's
there's a commonality among them I think
which is very telling and that is that
all of them feel it necessary to spend
significant time criticizing the
founding and they find it necessary to
do so they say because they say there's
something there in the founding that is
radically different than what we
progressives think is necessary for our
country under present circumstances and
so if if it's the case that there is
more of a continuity between the
founders and the progressives then some
of us might suggest it would seem to me
that that the argument has to has to
come up against the fact of what the
progressives themselves say okay I will
be happy to turn it over to audience
questions you guys someone has to point
and point them out to me because my
eyesight is failing
four-oh front row right here I would
like to address professor Barnett you
made an analogy of an airplane flying to
the Constitution if you violate the
Constitution that as its is being done
as many people believe that if an
airplane loses a multi-engine airplane
loses its engines and we can limp along
precariously as it would be having been
in the Air Force and flown I had a very
close friend who flew a British Jaguar
which was a twin-engine jet and I asked
him I said while you were flying with
the British was it a fun plane he's
always a great plane and I said it had
two engines if you lost an engine could
you continue to fly it he said all the
way to the scene of the accident
we're gonna let that stand without
comment in court Alvin I'll be
incorporating that into my lectures back
there yes yes this is a question for dr.
Arne dr. Eric do you combine dr. Barnett
and dr. de neens arguments and argue
that submission to natural law secures
natural rights and is the fundamental
duty of both the government and the
citizenry I want you to repeat that
key phrase if you do what to natural law
and natural rights submission to natural
law secures natural rights are you
interested in graduate school but I've
already got that kid so well first of
all I I saw I even think in relation
some of my colleagues here who've been
my teachers for four hundred years now
that I don't think those distinctions
are so important if you understand that
what's going on in the American
Revolution is politics and so they're
not writing treatises although they're
people who've read many and so what what
do they think do they doubt that it's
that you know if you promise a woman to
be her husband and take care of her and
she bears your children you want to keep
the promise nobody sign of course right
it's only today that we can come up with
a doubt about that and and so if that's
what you mean by the natural law natural
rights becomes a provision of it because
should as Lincoln said one man pray to
adjust God to wring the bread from the
sweat of other men's faces
that's a provision of natural rights and
natural law and so it seems to me that
those things have a way of collapsing
and
so now so so I don't think the
distinction logically is so important
now
brandy brings up a point that's really
good though and that is if we're going
to have a limited government there's
going to have to be a wide scope for us
to operate and we're going to have to
have really a limited government and
that means you're not gonna get arrested
for not going to church you know which
happened in Europe and in some New
England towns and you're not going to be
forbidden to vote because you go to the
wrong one and so and and you know that's
you know going to church in my little
opinion there's a really good thing and
I wish everybody go more and they could
put the football games off til later in
the day still have them but but you see
you see the point the point is you're
gonna have if you're gonna have a free
country and you're gonna have to have a
free country if you're gonna have
freedom of religion then this question
of Rights is going to be terribly
important and you're not gonna do more
than you have to do and then my argument
is then you can live people let people
work things out in their towns and that
you know until about 1930 more than 1935
more than 65% of the government of the
United States was carried on in economic
value terms in cities and towns and most
of the rest was counties and states and
the federal government was a small part
of it and that I submit is the
constitutional plan and I'll say one
more thing about that then because we
brought up if you look at what what Rome
was like when it began to grow and
conquer the known world
they were distinguished from their
neighbors because they were pious and
they were famous for being especially
protective of their women and their
families were very strong and of course
all you got to do is read about the
decline of Rome and what you find out is
there lies inches they betray their
women violence among the citizen body is
much more common their manners decline
terribly
and that's not the first time a
civilization could be has been conquered
by such things and our civilization if
you heard Tom West this morning may be
about to be conquered by such things but
at least in the case of Rome the fault
was not to be found in the Declaration
of Independence my question is for
professor Denis I was wondering if you
could elaborate on one of the points you
made about a problem possibly in the
constitution of relying mostly on
self-interest as the impetus behind
human action and ambition counteracting
ambition but obviously there's a there's
a problem that the progressives ran into
with a utopianist utopianist mindset of
claiming that we could conquer human
nature so I was just wondering if you
had a view of how the founders could
have better addressed human nature in
the founding rather than just focusing
on self-interest if you could elaborate
on that you should also consider
graduate school
sorry I'm just recruiting for Notre Dame
here that's a great question and I and I
guess when I talk about and this one
might all seem very strange to be
voguing so you get a political theory
seminar here without even without even
having perhaps wanting that but one of
the things that that I like when I talk
about this a break from antiquity I
think that the central thing that I'm
talking about here I wouldn't draw a
sharp a distinction as dr. Arnn between
the the antiquity of at least the
philosophical integrity of Greece in
Rome figures thinkers like Plato and
Aristotle and Cicero who exert a very
strong influence philosophically over
the Christian era and so I see less of a
radical break there that I think does
dr. Arnn and at the heart of it what I
want to call the Anthropology that's
fairly consistent indeed I would say
fundamentally consistent throughout all
those various periods of time is the
idea of a mixed human nature a mixing of
both beast eale and divine if I can put
it in those terms that we have whether
it's in the Greek tradition or in the
Christian tradition we have a great
propensity toward
either vice or sinfulness and we have a
great capacity for virtue or grace the
capacity to whether by our by our own
efforts but ultimately not our own
efforts to achieve a kind of the
imitation of Christ not to use the title
of a great a great text but that these
things are combined and they are an
inescapable fact about human beings and
one of the things that that it seems to
me to all the great thinkers of
antiquity including an Aristotle and an
aquinas struggle with is how do you
educate in some ways shape humans to
ascend to the highest capacity of their
natures educate the soul in virtue while
preventing the condition of their
falling into the most vicious capacities
that they may have and consistently
these thinkers think that what we're
calling government but that the public
world the very basis of the word
Republican Res Publica public things has
a role to play in that it's not to reach
into our souls and tell us how we should
live but it's to cultivate the soil
where families can raise their children
without fear of them watching the
television and where communities can
have a commerce without fears of shops
of pornography being opened and claiming
the rights of free speech etc it's that
kind of ground that for all of the
ancients cuz it's consistently thought
we have this great propensity toward
viciousness but this capacity toward
virtue and it takes great effort in
education an effort to cultivate that
higher part of our soul and if I would
fault
the move in the modern period it's that
each of these traditions we're talking
about the early modern liberal tradition
of the founders and the progressive
tradition each take a part of that
anthropology for the founders coming out
of the tradition of Machiavelli and
Hobbes and Locke they conclude that we
are really most fundamentally driven by
self-interest and we must organize our
institutions under the assumption that
the best we can do is harness that
interest and the progressives say no
we're not merely that
we can overcome our self-interest we can
become species beings as Mark says or we
can become members of the great
community as Dewey says by transcending
our sense of self and each of them in
some ways take a piece of that ancient
anthropology consistent with both the
ancient thinkers and the Christian
thinkers without the other piece and so
my argument is that in some ways if we
really want to correct our Constitution
our way of life our regime it requires
first a correction of our anthropology
of our assumption about human nature
contrast between the founders and the
progressives remember about the founders
that they think they're doing something
unprecedented and that is they're going
to base the whole policy of the
government the whole strength and
control of the government in the great
body of the people and they claim that's
never happened before and they think
that's because the people can be taught
as there is a degree of depravity in
mankind which requires a certain degree
of circumspection and distrust so there
are other qualities in human nature
which justify a certain portion of
esteem and confidence republican
government presupposes the existence of
these qualities in a higher degree than
any other form and you can understand
that as a qualification of the argument
in Federalist 10 about mechanism and
that argument itself if you read it
carefully also implies that there is a
good to which people will attract will
attach themselves identified as the
permanent and aggregate interest of the
community and that's from Federalists
indirectly and so this adventure
experiment they call it in America
that's the first time they claim that we
are going like the quote that Patrick
used at the beginning of his talk from
Federalist 1 about settle for all time
whether societies of men that means
everybody is going to get to choose and
that they're going to and that a
structure is going to be it's going
to be established so they choose well
and that structure is going to rely it's
in the 49th Federalist it says it is the
reason alone of the public that must be
placed in control of the government the
passions must be controlled by it but of
course the well-ordered sold in the
classical and the christian world is a
world is a soul in which the reason is
in charge of the passions and that's a
direct quote from madison and and and my
point is not that I'm not making a point
about Patrick right now I'm making a
point about the distinction between the
founders and the progressives which is
radical because remember the progressive
solution to government is to place a new
force a scientifically trained force
that's in all these office buildings
around here that is separate from the
public and exercise of control on the
society Rjay could I just say one thing
very quickly yes here's a fundamental
shift between the founding generation
and the progress was fundamental the
founders thought if you protect these
rights
things will work out the progresses
rejected the idea they said these rights
are standing in our way that's a
horse-and-buggy way of thinking it's a
horse-and-buggy constitution they stand
in our way what we need to do is instead
of enforcing those rights and let things
work out right and to find the rights
right and let things work out right
we've got to take all those rights we've
got to put them in the hands of the
experts and then they're gonna figure
out how to do public policy and that's
gonna make things right along a
scientific way that's a huge fundamental
paradigm shift and that and we're still
living with that paradigm shift but
that's if you want if you want to boil
it down to that there's a huge
difference there that we have to realize
that we're resisting and that what
really I think what liberals in the
classical sense should be for is the
reassertion of these rights and
understand by protecting these rights we
will yield better results overall then
if we take the rights away and give it
to some body of experts or or even the
majority to say well let them yield
better results so which one actually
gets the better results which one
actually ilds a society in which it
notes you can pursue happiness well
achieving peace and prosperity
I think the answer is the protection of
those rights is the way and that's what
we have to read
Thank You professor Barnett and thank
you to all our panelists I'm afraid
we're out of time and I have been
instructed by my superiors that I am to
encourage you to clear the room
expeditiously because I believe they're
actually setting up our lunch in this
room so so we'll see how well that goes
but again thank you very much